un ejemplo entre muchos otros de la
magnitud de la destrucción en boro janka
y de la enorme tarea de reconstrucción
que se avecina antes de la guerra estos
dos edificios eran uno solo pero un
bombardeo ruso a principios de marzo
destruyó la parte central ya no queda
nada 40 por ciento de las estructuras
están afectadas la reconstrucción parece
imposible pero los habitantes están
convencidos de que si es posible en este
barrio estos trabajadores se encargan
del primer paso la demolición de las
casas que están demasiado dañadas como
aquí estamos quitando las tuberías de
gas para que los demás servicios puedan
intervenir arrasar los edificios y
reconstruir otros nuevos una vez
terminada la búsqueda de las víctimas la
vida como era antes tardará meses
probablemente años en volver pero este
residente está dispuesto a esperar
volver un día no rendirse al enemigo a
pesar del trauma aunque nueve de sus
vecinos han desaparecido
vamos a quedarnos aquí hay que
reconstruir por odian acá tenemos que
ponernos a trabajar soy un antiguo
soldado no quiero irme
cuando todavía es posible como en estas
viviendas sociales los habitantes se
apresuran a reparar
será posible volver aquí tan pronto como
se restablezca al gas y la electricidad
tras la limpieza esta mujer procede al
inventario de lo que los ocupantes le
han robado
reconstruir es también volver a comprar
las ventanas se habían caído y las
reparamos pero nos robaron las joyas la
ropa la comida también creo que tenían
hambre incluso nos robaron la basura el
futuro devoró dianca dependerá de los
medios financieros que se le concedan
quién pagará por ejemplo las obras de
las numerosas casas destruidas los
habitantes a menudo no tienen el dinero
necesario y el estado ve como su
economía se hunde por la guerra por el
momento el 90 por ciento del flujo de
efectivo de la ciudad proviene de la
ayuda humanitaria